[Musique]
bonjour du tout la position dans
laquelle vous sentez le mieux ou sa
position de leader de suiveurs d'accord
c'est une question on vous dit que
c'était une vraie rencontre
mais c'est quoi pour vous une vraie
rencontre comment vous expliquer cette
crise de panique dans le métro qu'une
dépression mais c'est quand même dingue
de tomber sur quelqu'un qui a vraiment
vraiment mais rien à dire y a pas parlé
pendant une heure si l'on donné il m'a
dit j'ai l'impression que ça fait des
années que je te cherche ouest tu te
rappelles pas tournée karin huttary
votre belle karine karine paix 10,5 à
l'abattoir mais ces grandes d'accord
alors une brune à la ville et à des
boucles non les uns des 13 ans ont des
soucis dans sa tête
ça c'est pas tout ça c'est quoi moi là
et les restos et preston et ne suffit
pas d'avoir compris le problème pour
pouvoir régler le problème
john thain est absolument nécessaire
d'avoir compris le problème pour pouvoir
le régler le problème
ah non moi çà çà çà c'est pas beau ça
fait confiance à la vie
vous avez le droit d'être heureux
vous savez le droit d'être heureux de la
victoire tout arrive
m